So Leute, noch mal ganz schnell am Start. Ich hab mir gedacht, komm jetzt noch die letzte Stunde, mach's einfach mal streamern.
Wahrscheinlich keiner da. Also noch keiner da, denk ich mal, oder?
Test, test, jemand schon am Start. So quasi das Gegenstück zum Abobox Camper von früher auf YouTube.
Ah, yes. Excellent, excellent.
So, jetzt muss ich erst mal kurz die Emotes noch eine Runde kleiner machen.
Eine Runde den Chat Gachi bussen, solange er noch nicht da ist.
So, gut, passt wunderbar.
Ja Leute, also ich hab für diese Stunde jetzt, wo ich on bin, vielleicht ein paar Minuten länger, müssen wir mal gucken.
Ich hab nichts Großartiges mir ausgedacht, aber erst mal muss Twitch checken, dass der Stream online ist.
Jetzt hat's Twitch angeblich kapiert.
Wenn man Twitch glaubt, sind schon 13 Leute da. Excellent, Leute.
Exquisite. Ah, jetzt kommen die ersten Leute hier an den Start, ich seh schon.
Ja, du bist erster. Wobei laut Zuschauerzahlen bist du nicht erster, aber du bist definitiv erster, der was im Chat schreibt.
YouTube Krankheit, ja.
Du hast gesagt, was hast du gesagt?
Dass ich heute noch mal on komm.
KekWade
Luxemburg, excellent.
Da gibt's Steuern von Amazon, hab ich gehört.
Oder besser gesagt, es gibt dort relativ wenige Steuern von Amazon.
Wobei, wobei, Moment, sind die da überhaupt noch? Ist Amazon da überhaupt noch?
Haben die nicht umgesourced oder was auch immer?
Nee, nee, nee, nee, früher war Amazon war Luxemburg immer.
Neuseeland ist bester Land für reiche Menschen, das mag sein, aber dafür, ich gelte eventuell am Hand des Durchschnitts irgendwie als reich.
Aber erstens fühl ich mich nicht reich und zweitens bin ich für Neuseeland definitiv nicht reich genug.
Das ist eigentlich der Witz ab, was man mittlerweile schon als reich gilt.
Für mich ist jemand reich, der irgendwie drei goldene BMWs hat oder so.
Wobei ich mir, selbst wenn ich das Geld hätte, kein goldener BMW kaufen würde, aber ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Kengen ist auch am Start nice.
Google kommt jetzt auch, tja, würde ich auch so machen, also wenn ich so viel Kohle hätte, dann würde ich auch nach Luxemburg gehen.
Wie ist eigentlich so in Madeira oder wo irgendwie Amazon Steuersatz?
Kein Schimmer.
Wahrscheinlich auch ganz okay.
Ja, na klar, na klar, aber es geht mir auf den Sack, dass ich das mache.
Achso, du meinst, du meinst in Luxemburg, ja, in Luxemburg Spitzensteuersatz, weiß nicht, was der Spitzensteuersatz in Luxemburg für Leute wie Amazon.
4,5%? Keine Ahnung.
Echt, ist der jetzt auf Neuseeland? War der nicht in Australien?
Moment, der war auf Neuseeland und die sollten irgendwie ausliefern an die USA?
Was ist denn da eigentlich rausgekommen?
Was ist da eigentlich rausgekommen?
Wo ist der denn?
Der war mal Knossi im Stream, ja gut, das ist jetzt kein unbedingt große Auszeichnung, finde ich, aber kann man sich drüber streiten.
Wo ist der denn jetzt? Was macht der denn jetzt gerade?
Ah ja, Berufung, Berufung, Auslieferung. Achso.
Ganz im Ernst, ich würde auch an kein Land ausliefern, was irgendwelche komischen gefangenen, halboffiziellen gefangenen Lager hat.
Aber Kokona hat halt was zu sagen.
Der hat doch noch ein paar Mega-Millionen. Ja, ich hoffe es mal für ihn, weil das braucht er auch.
Der investiert auch in Krypto, ja, das macht, glaube ich, aktuell irgendwie jeder mit Huge-Stonks.
Also Leute, wie gesagt, ich bin bloß noch eine Stunde am Start.
Wisst ihr, was ich gemacht habe, bevor ich ongekommen bin? Ich habe endlich meine Waage an meinen Home Assistant angeschlossen.
Aber das zeige ich euch jetzt nicht.
Ich habe die Waage an mein Smart Home angeschlossen, dass ich weiß, wie fett ich bin und ob das rauf oder runter geht.
Ich habe hier so ein Ding hier.
Ich mache mal die VM an.
Es surft sich einfach angenehmer in der VM unter Linux.
Ach ja, wo wir gerade dabei sind, VM und Linux.
Hat jemand von euch auch diese Scam-E-Mails bekommen mit ihr Paket ist da aus dem Facebook-Leak?
Also ich habe einige gekriegt, aber habe ich euch ja schon erzählt vor, keine Ahnung, zwei Wochen oder so ist das schon her.
Hast du über 30 BMI? Nein, ich glaube 30 reicht nicht.
Ich habe nachgeguckt, also ich bin noch nicht fett genug, um mich früher impfen zu lassen.
Das hatte ich nachgeguckt, das habe ich euch auch mal erzählt vor, glaube ich, einem Monat oder so.
Genau, 40er BMI braucht man, so war es.
Genau, und ich bin nicht dick genug gewesen.
Es gibt jetzt also nur zwei Möglichkeiten, entweder ich warte auf einen normalen Impftermin oder ich nehme jetzt einfach so zu, dass ich 40 plus BMI habe.
30 ist Prio 3, na gut, Prio 3 ist quasi alle anderen, das ist 80, 70 und dann der Rest quasi.
Wie dick bist du? Ja, da hättest du dabei sein müssen im Stream, als wir die Waage eingerichtet haben.
Naja, sag mal so, ich bin auf jeden Fall nicht der Schlankste.
So, was soll ich jetzt sagen, ich habe ja dieses Teil hier.
Mi Scale, ich habe eine 2er.
Kurze Frage, weil ich gerade dran bin, meine ich, ich scroll mal kurz auf den Chat drüber.
Kurze Frage, weil ich gerade dran bin, schon Erfahrung mit Docker und IPv6 mache? Nö.
Muss man da irgendwas beachten, wenn man nur die 0, nein, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Habe ich noch nie ausprobiert, noch nie bewusst, aber nachdem IPv6 quasi eh immer standardmäßig an ist mittlerweile,
werde ich wahrscheinlich Docker auch schon über IPv6 gemacht haben, ohne dass ich es weiß.
Jaja, die geht ohne Internet, das ist ja gerade Sinn und Zweck der Sache gewesen.
Also ich habe dieses Teil hier als Waage.
Für Pippo Fettes, so sieht das aus, ist sogar tatsächlich relativ günstig, also so sieht das Ding aus.
Hallo, ich möchte da draufklicken.
Okay, da ist genau an der richtigen Stelle platziert.
Ja, so sieht das Teil aus und das Nice ist, das hat, man sieht es ja sicher, hier oben ist, das ist ja total beknackt gemacht,
also hier oben ist die eigentliche Anzeige, wie viel man wiegt.
Der Friseur, klar, der streamt auch öfters.
Hier oben ist die Anzeige, wie viel man wiegt und das Ganze geht ohne Internet, das überträgt über Bluetooth.
Und ich habe das jetzt eingerichtet, dass quasi der gleiche, der Coolchamp, der auch die Kühlschranktemperatur ausliest,
der liest jetzt auch das Ding aus.
Das habe ich jetzt hinten auf dem Klo stehen.
Ich habe da hinten auf dem Klo.
Moment, Moment, ich habe ja schon zu allem irgendwie Video gemacht, ich kann euch das ja alles zeigen.
Easy as fuck.
So, Max zeigt da, geht sofort.
Wie fett ist die Katze?
Ja, die wiegt auch, die wiegt auch ein bisschen mehr, aber es geht so.
So, Moment, ich muss warten, bis ich die Absenkautomatik zumache.
Moment, Moment, ich muss das Klo schließen.
Irgendwann mache ich das Klo zu.
Moment, habe ich das Klo am Anfang?
Moment, mache ich das Klo nie zu im Video?
Keck, wait, ich mache das Klo nie zu.
Ja, weil ich habe das Ding, guck mal, ihr Leute, hier unten ist eine...
Ups.
Strahler auf Maximum, ja klar.
In your face strahlen.
So, hier hinten ist eine Steckdose.
Ich habe hier hinten so ein spritzwasserdichtes 9 Cent Gehäuse hingelegt mit einem Controller,
hängt hier unten an der Steckdose und macht Empfang für die Waage und für die Mi Flora Sensors.
Und der wird auch noch Empfang machen für diesen...
Für das Ding, das was wir letztens geflasht haben im Stream.
Für das Teil, das haben wir auch geflasht, das ist so ein Thermometer an der Wand.
Und dann kann ich aus dem Bad übertragen lassen, Temperatur, Luftfeuchtigkeit.
Ich kann damit dann quasi auch die Heizung steuern.
Also mit dem Regler, der an der Heizung dran ist, kann ich dann anhand von Temperatur und Luftfeuchtigkeit,
also anhand von Temperatur, das einrichten.
Also je nachdem, sprich ich kann am Beispiel das Wagen, es ist ein Wochentag,
ich muss auf die Arbeit fahren, das ist nach 6.30 Uhr.
Oder besser ist es nach 5.45 Uhr, je nachdem wann ich fahre.
Und dann geht schon mal die Heizung an und sowas, das ist eigentlich richtig nice.
Ob ich auf dem Klo bin, kacken kann man damit leider nicht kontrollieren.
Aber das ist äußerst nice, siehste?
Und jetzt kriege ich den ganzen Kram direkt live in mein Home Assistant gestellt.
Ohne Flaschen, ja es hat aber Vorteile das Zeug zu Flaschen.
Erstens, also erstmal muss man sagen, das zu Flaschen ist total einfach.
Haben wir letztens im Stream gemacht, das Stream hab ich gelöscht.
Ich hab mir überlegt, ich lösch diese ganzen Hacker-Man-Streams.
Erstens, weil ich nicht weiß, ob Twitch mal den YouTube macht und Hacker-Kram irgendwie bunt.
Weiß man ja nie.
Und das Zweite ist, weil es immer mal sein kann, dass ich da aus Versehen ohne,
dass ich mitkrieg irgendwelche Mac-Adressen und sowas leake.
Und das muss ich ja nicht unbedingt mehr in der Welt rum posauen, als eh schon ist.
Sind die im Archiv? Nein, das ist nicht im Archiv.
Deswegen, die sollen auch nicht ins Archiv.
Weil wie gesagt, falls ich da irgendwelche Dinge aus Versehen mal leake, ohne dass ich selbst merke, dann ja.
Streams, die länger online sind als ein Tag, also wenn ich mir da sicher bin,
dass ich nichts aus Versehen gezeigt hab, wenn ich beispielsweise ein paar Sachen flasche,
ohne dass ich mal einen Raspberry Pi Netzwerkscan gemacht oder sowas,
dann lass ich die drin, dann kommen die auch ins Archiv.
Aber manche Streams, wo ich mit letzten Streams war, ich bin nicht so sicher,
ob ich nicht irgendwie Mac-Adressen und sonst viel geleakt hab.
Ich mein, das ist jetzt ja nicht schlimm, aber muss ja auch nicht unbedingt sein.
Und dann hab ich die erstmal wieder gelöscht.
Ja, so sieht's aus.
Also wie gesagt, kann ich dir empfehlen zu flashen, weil die Batterie hält länger, wenn du's geflasht hast.
Du kannst den Intervall runterstellen, das Standardintervall,
wo dieses Thermostat alle 2,5 Sekunden meldet, dieses Thermostat, das ist viel zu oft.
Ich hab das runtergestellt auf 10 Sekunden, das reicht dicke.
Ich mein, als würde sich die Temperatur bei mir im Bad alle 2,5 Sekunden ändern.
Weiß ich, wie ist das bei euch im Bad?
Ist da auch alle 2,5 Sekunden immer eine andere Temperatur?
Zumindest hab ich das jetzt hochgestellt auf 10 Sekunden
und eigentlich kann ich's locker hochstellen auf 5 Minuten und dann hält die Batterie auch eine ganze Weile.
Ja, 2 Minuten, 2 Minuten ist gut.
Vielleicht mach ich auch 5 Minuten, aber 2 Minuten ist eigentlich ganz gut.
Too hot.
Ja, zumindest sehr nice, krieg ich jetzt alles in Home Assistant.
Und kann mir zugucken beim P-Po-Fat sein.
Wie lange hält der denn so? Das weiß ich noch nicht.
Also da kommt so eine ganz normale Knopfzelle rein, das ist so eine CR2032 Batterie, so ein Ding,
das hat irgendwie 350mAh in dem Dreh.
Das ist jetzt nicht der Wahnsinn, ne?
Du kannst das überhaupt nicht ausschalten, mit der Standard-Firmware.
Sebi, du kannst das überhaupt nicht ausschalten.
Der Sensor sendet immer alle 2,5 Sekunden, ob du den fragst oder nicht.
Habt ihr ein Interview gesehen?
Ein Interview?
Ach, meinst du das? Moment, äh...
Meinst du das?
Das hier?
Oder was für ein Interview?
Was ist das denn für ein Interview?
Das hier? Oder was für ein Interview?
Also er hat mich ja so... Ach ja, ok. Er hat mich ja quasi so interviewt.
Eigentlich haben wir 20 Minuten gelabert über Ausbildung und sonst was.
Er hat ja Anwendungsentwicklung gelernt.
Ich würde es weniger Interview nennen, aber es war das Einzige, was es sein konnte.
Es war das Einzige, was es sein konnte.
Ja, das ist wurscht. Who cares?
Ich will Kali in... Was, in Visual Basic?
Ach, Virtual Box?
Ähm, ist eigentlich ziemlich egal, was du da vorne auswählst.
Wähl irgendein Standard-Ding aus, Debian, Ubuntu oder sonst wie.
Das macht kaum einen Unterschied.
Bei Vmware kannst du auch irgendwie Generic, Kernel, 5.6 oder so auswählen.
Ja, das ist eigentlich ziemlich wurscht, was du da nimmst.
Wichtiger ist, was du für Hardware einstellst.
Wisst ihr eigentlich, wie Pepega Bluetooth-Zeugs auszulesen ist?
Welches ist er noch? Das ist FFZ.
Kannst du das Ding empfehlen?
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Alter!
Was ist das für ein Preis, Alter?
Was soll das überhaupt sein?
Verstehe nicht.
Eine Fernbedienung?
Kannst du auswählen...
Nee, da mache ich schon mal ein Video zu.
Sieht ein bisschen aus wie eine Universal-Fernbedienung, ja?
Arbeitest du hier?
Arbeitest du eigentlich noch am Preis-Champ?
Nee.
Oh, mal gucken, ob der kaputt ist.
Da geht der manchmal kaputt.
Oh, fuck, der ist wieder kaputt.
Der geht ja alle paar Tage kaputt.
Keck, Wade.
Muss ich nachher noch mal neu starten.
Treibe ich mir gleich mal auf.
Also, der Preis-Champ geht nicht kaputt.
Der Crawler geht kaputt.
Du hast deinen E-Scooter geflasht.
Was machst du, wenn sie dich kontrollieren?
Toss, Anzeige ist raus.
Ich habe es am Anfang mit Signal A gemacht,
aber jetzt ist das alles CraftQL.
CraftQL Websocket Notifications.
Es können sein, dass noch die eine oder andere Signal A-Geschichte drin ist.
Bin ich mir nämlich ganz sicher.
Aber das Meiste auf jeden Fall ist CraftQL.
Wo kann ich Raspberry Pi günstig kaufen?
Auf Amazon.
Oder das hier ist auch gut.
Da kaufe ich öfters mal was.
Dann wurde im Stream öfters mal das da empfohlen.
Da habe ich aber noch nichts bestellt.
Aber die haben, glaube ich, keinen deutschen Shop mehr.
Also, wenn ich mir einen kaufen würde,
würde ich das mal hier vergleichen.
Und mal ganz im Ernst, ich glaube,
du fährst mit Amazon gar nicht so schlecht.
Lass es doch mal vergleichen.
Das ist ein Pi 4 2G.
Was kostet der auf Amazon?
4 2 G.
Ah, den gibt es da gerade gar nicht.
Sollte ich mich veräppeln?
Warum soll ich dir das Doppel dafür ausgeben?
Kack wait.
Da, wenn du nicht weißt, was du mit dem machen sollst,
kannst du dir das Doppel dafür ausgeben.
Das ist ein Kack wait.
Wenn du nicht weißt, was du mit dem machen sollst,
dann würde ich es einfach sein lassen.
Warum ist das so teuer?
Was ist das?
Was ist mit VMWare?
Nee, geht, geht.
Du musst einfach bei einem Keyshop
oder bei einer Softwareresale-Seite
deiner Wahl gucken.
Da bekommst du die Lizenz schon für 25 Euro.
Da wäre ich mir nicht so sicher.
Die sind ja nicht blöd.
Genau, also in VMWare habe ich beispielsweise das hier.
Guck, das hier.
Mein Linux Desktop läuft hier in der VM.
Ich habe Windows als Host.
Und ich kann Windows Desktop wechseln.
Und ich kann Windows Desktop wechseln
in die Linux VM rein oder so.
Und dann habe ich hier nochmal extra Desktop.
Ich habe quasi virtuelle Desktop
in virtuellen Desktop.
Das ist absolut Next-Level-Fivehead-Gramm.
Das machen nur High IQ Leute.
Und das geht auch nur, weil der Chat
immer so viel subscribt.
Weil ihr wisst ja, für jeden Sub
gibt es einen IQ-Punkt mehr für den gesamten Chat.
Und für mich.
Weil bei mir bin ich mir da nicht so sicher.
Any Primers,
die gerade dabei sind. IQ++, ja.
Also ganz ehrlich, wenn dir nichts
einfällt, lass es.
Das hat keinen Sinn.
Das hat im Prinzip keinen Sinn,
sich da sinnlos Hardware zu kaufen und dann
die üblichen Verdächtigen zu machen.
Das sind halt so die Standard-Dinger.
Die finde ich jetzt auch nur,
sagen wir mal, begrenzt sinnvoll, wenn man
da kein richtiges Anwendungsgebiet hat.
Das ist ganz nice, aber
braucht man eigentlich nicht, wenn man hauptsächlich am Desktop unterwegs ist.
VPN, falls man es braucht, ja.
NAS würde ich halt auch nicht auf
Raspberry Pi machen. Viele kann man machen,
aber Raspberry Pi ist kein gutes, kein Gott,
kein gutes Board für ein ordentliches NAS.
Ja, und Home Assistant oder Heimautomatik
ist auf jeden Fall eine coole Sache,
die man mit dem Raspberry Pi machen kann, aber
wenn man da keinen Anwendungszweck für hat,
dann lohnt sich eigentlich auch nicht.
Ich glaube, man wollte Hab schreiben, nicht Ub.
Ja, ja, wir haben noch jede Menge.
Mal da, Flub.
Jede Menge Zeug.
Nee, nee, NAS, also,
es geht, aber
sonnenlich gut ist
ein NAS auf Raspberry Pi nicht.
Tja,
wie noch keine Kredite auf,
noch kein Kredit aufgenommen für Twitch-Subs.
Weil ich frage mich,
wie die ganzen Pool-Streamer, Top-Donator
das machen. Die verschulden sich
sicherlich dafür, warum auch immer.
Da gab es doch den
Typ, da gab es
doch diesen Typ, der bei
Ninja, was, bei Ninja?
Einer der Ninja Top-Donator, wo raus
gekommen ist, dass der
mit, dass der dann irgendwann
arbeitslos geworden ist und quasi sein ganzes
und ich glaube sogar inklusive
Haus und so alles rausgehauen hat für Streamer-Donation,
dass er auf Twitch, ich habe
vergessen, wie dieser Dude heißt,
dass er auf, dass es aussieht, als ist er voll die große Nummer.
Der war nicht nur
bei Ninja vorne mit dabei,
mit Donation, also der hat auch, der hat auch
bei Grill-Streamer
und so alles fett Donated.
Wie hieß der denn? Z Ninja
Donator
Äh
GoFundMe
Moment
Donator
Hier, das da!
Ob das jetzt so eine
seriöse Quelle ist, sei mal dahingestellt.
Aber der Typ
Ja
AC Royale
So, und der Typ ist
So, der Typ hat, ähm
Der hat, der hat so viel Donated
Nee, nee, das ist kein super reicher
aus, achso der, äh, ja es gibt
es gibt einige ultra
Massive-Geld-Typen, die
übelst Donaten auf Twitch. Aber
das hier ist halt hart, ne? Der hat so viel
Donated, dass er selbst pleite
ist.
Der hatte quasi, weiß nicht,
Donationsucht oder so.
Äh, by the way, ich hab damit keine
Probleme, wenn einer von euch Donationsucht
hat. Also, äh,
Bits und, äh,
ich hab auch zur Not einen PayPal-Überweisungslink
ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Können wir machen.
Immer rein, genau
immer rein.
Stonks, alter.
Übrigens, wo wir gerade beim Thema Stonks sind
nicht das und ich, ich muss immer mehr
Steuern bezahlen, wenn ich was verdiene, aber nicht mehr
Steuersatz glücklicherweise.
Guck mal hier.
Ich hab jetzt, weiß keine, ob man das hier
sieht.
Ja, man siehts hier nicht richtig. Also ich hab zum ersten
Mal in meinem Leben
284k Subscriber.
Oh, was sagt Hetzner?
Stimmt, da war heut Montag, ich guck mal rein. Ich hab
auch gar nicht geguckt.
Äh, ich mein ich hab seit irgendwie 8 Jahren 200k
oder so.
Einfach weil ich, weil ich nichts...
Leku, jetzt nicht übertreiben hier, das war doch ein Witz,
weißt du doch. 50 Cent, alter.
50 Billionen Euro am Start.
Zeig mal her.
Leku, danke schön für die Massive,
für die Massive Huge Bits.
Zeig mal, 50, 100,
200, 300,
400, 450, also 5 Euro
ungefähr.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wieviel ich anteilmäßig bezahlen muss.
An Bits.
Krieg ich Bits? Krieg ich Bits komplett?
Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt gar nicht.
Ihre Bestellung wurde
verschickt.
Nutzen sie jetzt? Ok, Moment, da muss ich mal
kurz, ne wobei. Guck mal,
später.
Keck wait.
Äh...
Kooperation ist einfach mit Hetzner. Die haben geantwortet.
Poggers.
Ok, ok, ok, ich muss mal kurz gucken.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken, was die geantwortet haben.
Ah, nice, nice, nice. Bald gibt's
excellent Hetzner
Placement.
Nice, ach und NordVPN
ist auch wieder am Start.
Na, die dürfen natürlich nicht fehlen bei sowas.
Also Leute,
easy.
Bald gibt's... Ich hab mich mit
Ihnen ein bisschen Gedanken gemacht.
Nein, nein, mit NordVPN mach ich nichts.
Lull. Die Leute,
die sind nur am Start in E-Mails. Ich mach doch
kein NordVPN Video.
Außer die bezahlen richtig fett Kohle.
Da mach ich ein NordVPN Video, Alter.
Ähm...
Ja, weil ich hab mir den abgesprochen.
Man könnte ja so ne Werbung machen, wie es der Bauer
gemacht hat.
Also, äh, ne?
Also einfach am Anfang, man macht sein Intro
fürs Video und dann macht man einfach so 20
Sekunden.
Ähm, dieses Video ist
ein Sponsor von Hetzner, euer Cloud-Anbieter,
bla, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Und, äh, dann gibt's Big Stunks
für alle Beteiligten.
Zumal,
das Witzige ist,
dass ich tatsächlich, dass ich tatsächlich
ja auch überzeugt von der Sache bin.
Dementsprechend kann ich auch tatsächlich sagen, dass das
meiner Meinung nach, zumindest in Deutschland,
definitiv der beste Cloud-Anbieter ist, was
Preis-Leistung angeht. Ich sag nicht, dass es
der ultimative beste
äh, ne? Cloud-Anbieter
ist, aber zumindest Preis-Leistungsmäßig ist
in Deutschland definitiv der beste. Für mich
international auch. Ähm, weil
du kriegst für die Hälfte von
Digital Ocean kriegste da ne
Kiste. Und letztendlich, was juckt
mich denn? Was juckt mich denn?
Ob das Desktop-Hardware ist oder nicht.
Das ist mir doch scheißegal.
Solange das ordentlich, ordentlich
Rechenleistungen
und RAM für das Geld gibt.
Ob da jetzt Server-Hardware drunter ist
oder nicht, ist mir doch vollkommen egal.
Sind es trotzdem, sind es eh irgendwelche
KVM-VMs oder sonst was.
Was weiß...
Was juckt mich denn? Ob das
Server-CPU ist oder Desktop-CPU, macht
überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
So.
Genau, also den hier wollte ich euch zeigen, das ist der, der sich
pleite donated hat.
Ähm...
Was hältst du vom Elektrotechnik-Studium?
Wisst ihr, was das geile ist? Ich mach mittlerweile schon
so lang Videos, dass ich zu fast jedem
Video schonmal, dass ich zu fast jedem
Thema schonmal ein Video gemacht hab.
Elektrotechnikor
haben wir es glaub ich genannt.
Nein. Elektrotechnik.
Ich hab ein Video.
Ich glaub mit dem Nielson
hab ich das gemacht.
Ich hab ein Video
gemacht mit einem Elektrotechniker.
Nicht
Kieler Junge. Ich hab ein Video
gemacht mit einem der Elektrotechnik studiert
und...
Ich müsste es jetzt bloß noch finden.
Hier.
Das Elektrotechnikor-Studium
Alter von 2014. Ich glaub
da hat sich nicht allzu viel geändert.
Sarex, wie hast du das so schnell gefunden?
Ich dachte ja schon immer, ich bin relativ schnell
im googeln, aber der Chat ist mir da
relativ.
So mittendrin mal
Bäm. Hab ich Bäm gesagt dem Video?
Wahrscheinlich hab ich Bäm gesagt.
In your face, Alter.
Hier gibt's heute
nix grossartiges zu sehen.
Nee, nee.
Das ist, wenn sogar der Chat meint,
das ist ein zukunftssicherer Job, dann ist das
definitiv, weil wir wissen ja der Chat hat bei so was
prinzipiell immer recht. Also
ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht.
Fällt euch eine Gelegenheit ein, wo der Chat mal
nicht recht hatte. Also ich kann jetzt
da eigentlich, fällt mir da... Nee.
Das geht, das glaub ich noch nie vorgekommen.
Oder?
Ich glaub
der Chat hat schon immer recht.
Der Twitch
Chat ist ja auch bekannt dafür,
besonders qualitativ
hochwertige Antworten zu geben. Besonders
wenn man mal zu XQC
in den Chat guckt oder so, da ist der Chat
natürlich ganz besonders
big brain.
Oder wenn ihr noch big
big brainige Chats sehen wollt, müsst ihr euch
Poolstreams angucken.
Leute, ich hab mal eine ernst gemeinte
Frage. Jetzt wirklich?
Was versprechen sich die Leute davon,
die fett donaten
für Poolstreams?
In Poolstreams.
Weil ich mein, ob die jetzt meinen Namen
sich auf den Oberschenkel schreibt oder nicht, dafür
donate ich ja nicht, oder? Also das kann's
ja eigentlich nicht sein.
Was juckt's mich?
Das kann
doch eigentlich nur
sag mal so Aufmerksamkeit
im Stream sein, dass die Leute sagen
Alter, guck mal, der hat donatet.
Oder
meint ihr, es gibt wirklich
Leute
die donaten
also das glaub ich, also was heißt
die Frage, die Frage ist falsch gestellt.
Ich glaube, dass es Leute gibt, die donaten.
Also mal von den Aufmerksamkeits
Leuten, die das für Publicity
auf Twitch und sich geil fühlen, weil so viele sehen,
mal abgesehen. Ich glaube, es gibt
wirklich Leute, die donaten
Krillstreamer, weil sie denken,
sie haben damit eine Chance bei denen.
Kann ich mir echt vorstellen.
Also,
wohlgemerkt, ich rede jetzt hier nicht, ich rede hier
von Pool- und Boopcam-Streams.
Jetzt nicht von Mädels,
die normale Sachen streamen.
Das sag ich ja nichts gegen.
Das sind
mehr als zu sehr, das glaub ich auch.
Da, Phil,
für den Prime-Sub.
Die juckt das nie.
Die juckt das Geld, aber
doch nicht der Typ, der dahinter steht und donatet.
Ganz ehrlich, würde mich an der Stelle
an Boopcam-Streamer-Stelle auch nicht interessieren.
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Vor allem, was ich auch nicht kapiere,
ist, also wenn die Leute
da irgendwelche
Salami-Absichten haben
in diesen Streams, das
verstehe ich gar nicht, ehrlich gesagt,
weil dafür
gibt es so viele Dinge,
wo quasi, teilweise
die gleichen Mädels, die auf Twitch-Pool-Streamen
machen, dann quasi zu anderen
Uhrzeiten dort richtig
streamen.
Und dann sollen die Leute einfach da donaten.
Egal, ich muss es nicht
verstehen.
Ich will es auch nicht, ich will es eigentlich gar nicht so genau
Ja, wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich.
Ich weiß nicht.
Komisch.
Machst du da Bitcoin-Kurs?
Ausbildung oder Studio mit 26?
Was willst du denn machen,
Yexu? Was würdest du machen?
Aber unabhängig davon von deinem Alter,
wonach ist es dir denn?
Oh.
Moment. Ah.
Ah,
schon mal.
Exquisite.
Quatsch, passt.
Das geht.
Ja, du hast recht, es gibt bestimmt welche, die gucken komisch,
aber ist kein Problem.
Hat auch seine Vorteile.
Äh.
Wo hat er denn geschrieben?
Moment.
Äh.
Yexu.
Hat er schon was geantwortet?
Wie gesagt, wir hatten in der Berufsschule
auch Leute, die älter sind.
Das ist kein Problem.
Es kann sein, ich bin mir da nicht sicher,
es kann sein, dass wenn du nicht mehr
schulpflichtig bist, dass du dich irgendwie, glaub
auch sogar von der Berufsschule irgendwie befreien lassen kannst
oder so.
Ich bin hingegangen, obwohl ich auch schon über
21 war. Ich mein, ich war, lass mal
überlegen Leute.
Ich war glaub ich auch,
ich mein, ich hab ja vorher noch diese
noch kaufmännischen Kram
versucht zu machen, wo ich
heute Abneigung fürs Leben zu hab.
Deswegen.
Ähm.
Also ich bin 1984 geboren. Was war
2007?
Was war 2007?
Ja, da war ich 2007, Leute.
Big Brain.
2000 war ich 16.
Da war ich 23, hä?
Ja.
Gut, dann siehst du?
Dann war ich in der Ausbildung
mit 23.
Jaja, Leute.
Wir brauchen auch Wupp Boomer.
Ist der Chainlord da?
Wobei wir haben Wupp Boomer,
wir haben Wupp Old, das reicht.
Also ich kann mich dran erinnern,
ich hab meinen Vertrag unterschrieben,
meinen Ausbildungsvertrag, bevor es das iPhone
gab. Das weiß ich noch.
Also ich kann mich noch
dran erinnern, als ich in der Ausbildung
war, als das iPhone rausgekommen ist. Deswegen
weiß ich, dass ich mein Angriff, dass ich definitiv
angefangen hab, bevor das iPhone rausgekommen ist
und dass ich auch unterschrieben
hab, das Jahr davor dann. Also sprich,
ähm...
Ich weiß doch genau,
wo die Leute rumgeflitzt sind bei uns
wegen iPhone, wollten gleich gucken, ob
jemand eins hat und so.
Was hattest du...
Was hattest du zu der Zeit?
Äh, ich hatte ein...
Wartet mal, das hatte ich übrigens
jahrelang noch. Ich war
ja richtig, richtig, richtig boomermäßig.
Ich hatte ja, ich hatte ja glaube ich, bis
2000...
Keine Ahnung, bis 2010
oder so.
Ich hatte ja erst ein Smartphone ab 2010,
glaube ich, oder sowas. Ich war da richtig
langsam.
Ich hatte vorher irgendwie so ein komisches
Siemens A.
Äh, frag mich nicht, Handy.
So ein blauer, so ein Teil hier, so ein blaues,
Alter.
Kein Quake, Alter.
So ein Teil hatte ich, genau.
Der Kram,
der hatte immerhin Snake drauf, ja.
Das ist recht...
Das ist aber gar nicht so groß gewesen.
Das... Moment, das kann man kaufen?
Wait a minute.
Moment, das kann man kaufen?
Wow!
117 Euro!
Alter, meine Güte, ist ja...
Moment, das war was anderes.
Okay, ne, das gibt's, das gibt's nicht mehr.
Gibt's nicht mehr.
Das hätte mich jetzt auch echt gewundert, wenn es so ein Crap noch gäbe.
Man kann's auf D-Tronic kaufen,
was auch immer das ist.
Ich...
Ich muss sagen, ich hab mich nie für Handys interessiert.
Ich hab mich nie für Handys interessiert.
Mein Interesse kam dann wirklich erst, als
das Smartphone gab an der ganzen Geschichte.
Und ich hab mich auch lange nicht
für Smartphones großartig interessiert.
Ich hab mich heute noch immer noch nicht großartig für Smartphones.
Da gibt's aber auch ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so viel,
wo man sich dafür interessieren kann.
Das hat dann erst so ein bisschen angefangen,
als ich
ein iPhone... Was war denn das?
In welcher Reihe? Mal mal.
iPhone History, was kam denn da raus?
In welcher Reihenfolge?
Was ich aktuell hab, ich hab
ein XR
und noch ein
iPhone 6, aber das verwende ich da immer.
Hallo?
In welcher Reihenfolge kam der Kram denn raus?
iPhone 1, iPhone 2? Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr.
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr. Gibt's da irgendwie eine gute History?
Ja, 3.
Ja, hier, das hatte ich. Das hatte ich.
Ich glaube, ich hatte einen...
Den 4S war das Zweite, was ich hatte.
Den 4S war das Zweite.
Dann hatte ich, glaube ich, so eins
oder so eins
oder... Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Ich hab das ja von der Firma damals gekriegt
als Handy,
was man auch privat verwenden darf.
Und sonst hätte ich mir wahrscheinlich
gar keins gekauft. Ich war damals schon zu
boomer für Smartphone.
Ja, gut, heute hast du mit 5 schon ein Smartphone.
Ja, was kam jetzt hier eigentlich raus mit
Studium?
Ich hab mit dem Wombo eins zum Mathe-Studium gemacht.
Das ist noch gar nicht so lange her.
Hattest du schon Siri?
Ich hab heute noch nicht mal Siri.
Ich glaube, das erste iPhone, was ich hatte,
hatte noch kein Siri, nee.
Okay, er hat nicht mehr drauf geantwortet.
Ja, gut, dann...
Ach doch, hier! Eigentlich Studium,
aber ich sollte endlich mal richtig arbeiten gehen.
Na gut, kommt drauf an, ob die Kohle langt
oder nicht. Also, in der Regel,
wenn es irgendwie machbar ist,
würde ich ganz ehrlich sagen,
man sollte das machen, wo man am meisten Bock drauf hat.
Wenn du dir das zutraust und das ist, was du machen willst,
du solltest dich im Vorfeld zumindest mal
ein bisschen drüber informieren,
weil ich glaube, dass gerade was Informatik-Studium angeht,
viele Leute da Technik-Stells erwarten
und mit Hardware, Computer-Kram
hat das Ganze gar nichts zu tun.
Und das ist halt sehr viel
Mathe und theoretische Sachen,
es sei denn,
man macht so komische Sachen
wie Wirtschaftsinformatik, aber da ist
Wirtschaft dabei, da hätte ich persönlich keinen Bock drauf.
Aber das muss ja
jeder selbst wissen.
Ich glaube, es geht mehr darum, dass...
Okay, was? Hä?
Moment.
Ich muss runter scrollen, ich bin...
Ja, nice, nice, nice.
Das Video ist eh übelst gut angekommen.
Welche Frage soll ich beantworten?
What?
Nein, mit Ingenieursinformatik hatte nichts zu tun.
Ich sehe hier nichts, was ich beantworten soll.
Exquisite.
So, Crap Handy, Crap Handy.
Genau, was ich eigentlich ursprünglich sagen wollte,
ist, vielleicht schaffe ich
dieses Jahr 300k.
Da muss ich aber mich echt
ins Zeug legen und auch ein paar
Videos produzieren, die
echt gut ankommen.
Dann wird das was.
Wenn man 2-3 Videos macht, ohne Scheiß,
2-3 Videos, die gut ankommen,
dann sind das schon auf einen Schlag
einfach mal
4-5k Abos.
Du brauchst 2-3 Videos, die richtig
gut ankommen.
Und ich sollte nochmal
an Bewerbungs-Dings,
die kamen nämlich immer echt gut an.
Die Stellenanzeigen-Videos.
Doch, doch, doch, meine
Abozahl hat sich verändert. Die letzten Jahre
ging die ja eher runter, weil ich nichts gemacht hab.
Ich hab aktuell so viele
Abos wie noch nie vorher.
Also ich hab jetzt quasi alles wieder aufgeholt,
was ich verloren hab die letzten 6 Jahre.
Meine Firma war
in der Stellenanzeige, kam aber gut weg.
Das ist doch nice.
Aber auch mal kann nicht alles kacke sein.
Nee, das ist nicht sinnlos. Das ist sinnlos.
Ich brauch richtige Abos, außerdem ist das verboten.
Machen trotzdem welche,
aber das ist ja sinnlos.
Du hast wegen dem Stellenanzeigen-Video
bei der Bahn angefangen, okay?
Die Bahn ist ja in dem Video nicht so gut weggekommen.
Was ich übrigens lustig fand,
die, ähm,
die einen haben sogar drauf geantwortet, ne?
Moment, wo sind die denn? Da haben welche drauf geantwortet.
Haben die das wieder gelöscht?
Die hatten drauf geantwortet,
die Typen, die ich als erstes gezeigt hatte.
Und auch keine schlechte Antwort, ja?
Haben die das gelöscht?
Twitter.
Die haben auch auf Twitter, die haben überall geantwortet.
Auf YouTube, auf Twitter.
Moment, das muss ich jetzt mal überprüfen,
ob die das gelöscht haben.
Das finde ich ja relativ schnell.
Das war irgendwann im Dezember.
Bringst die Katz steht neuerdings voll auf mein stinkisches Hemd,
ich weiß auch nicht warum.
So, auf Twitter, gib, gib Gas.
Come on.
Hier, da ist es.
Ach nee, das ist nicht das.
Come on.
Hier, da ist es.
Ach nee, das ist die zweite, die zweite.
Jaja, das war im Dezember.
Hier.
Die haben das gelöscht, oder?
Ah nee, da sind sie.
Warum wurde das ausgeblendet?
Ich hab das nicht ausgeblendet.
Vielleicht.
Die haben,
ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass die hier geantwortet haben.
By the way, daran sieht man mal wieder,
soll ich euch mal was sagen, ich muss so übelst rumragen jetzt.
Endless Scroll ist der,
ist absolut Cancer auf Webseiten.
So ne Scheiße, warum macht jede Webseite
Endless Scroll, so ne Kacke.
Die sollen vielleicht,
also wenn die Endless Scroll machen,
dann sollen sie wenigstens Search-Balken hier oben einbauen,
oder sowas.
Ach, da ist es doch, hier, da.
Guck hier, also die haben es gleich drauf geantwortet.
Aber ohne Scheiß, Endless Scroll
ist absoluter Crap.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wozu gibt es überhaupt
Endless Scroll, ich mein, guckte mal.
Das Video hat
7 Monat Comments.
Meint YouTube ernsthaft?
7 Monat Comments schafften aktuelle
Rechner nicht zu laden auf einer Seite,
oder was?
Was ist denn die Alternative?
Naja, einfach die Sachen untereinander darstellen.
Fertig. Einfach komplett laden.
Bäm.
Ist doch kein Problem. Kannste machen.
Alternativ
machst du einfach verschiedene Seiten, die du durchklicken kannst.
Also so wie früher.
Seite 1, Seite 2, Seite 3.
Das kann man auch machen. Da kann man sich zumindest merken,
auf welcher Seite irgendwas war.
Oh, da gibt es den Addon zu, zeigt mal.
Suche Kommentare auf YouTube. Was sind das für
eine Name für den Addon?
Der Eugene
Guba hat das gemacht.
YouTube Comment Search
Ok, wollen wir das mal ausprobieren?
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus. Easy.
Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus.
YouTube Comment Search. Für Chrome verfügbar.
Bäm. Ah, Moment.
Moment, Moment. Chrome, Chrome.
Exquisite Chrome.
Zack.
Hier, machen wir mal auf,
im Chrome. Und jetzt
das im Chrome.
Was, ai ai ai,
erschreckt mich nicht so.
Ok, hinzufügen.
Add.
Lass mal Virus einfangen.
Nein nein, Max, halt die Klappe.
So, wo ist das Addon hin?
Hier.
Open Video
Ok.
Ah, funktioniert nicht.
Aber da muss man erstmal laut sagen.
So eine Crap überhaupt braucht dafür, dass das funktioniert, äh...
Chat? Gibt's da ein Chat?
Okay, die Sache funktioniert. Das ist ein gutes Addon.
Aber das ist echt mal der Witz, oder?
Das ist so Crap, dass man nicht einfach mal... Ach, man kann da oben auch Load All klicken.
Es ist so fail einfach nur, dass es diese Endless Scroll-Geschichte gibt.
Und wisst ihr was auch übelst fail ist?
Ähm, dass diese Sortierfunktion, die ist maximal useless.
Ich mein, most popular lasse ich mir noch gefallen.
Newst lasse ich mir auch gefallen. Oldest ist auch okay.
Aber warum kann ich nicht nach Monaten oder Jahr sortieren?
Vielleicht, guck mal, ich mein, vielleicht weiß jemand,
ah, der Max, der hat doch mal, als ich die Ausbildung angefangen hab, ungefähr ein Video gemacht.
Das müsste 2016 sein.
Warum gibt es keinen Knopf? Einfach 2016.
Oder, warum gibt es hier unten nicht wenigstens was?
Ich mein, guckt euch das mal an.
Wenn ich ein Video suche, muss ich jetzt erstmal eine halbe Stunde
dieses fucking Endless Scroll-Ding nach unten scrollen.
Ich weiß, die Technologie ist einfach noch nicht da dafür.
Die Technologie ist einfach noch nicht da.
Die ging zwar vor 15 Jahren schon, aber das geht nicht.
So, jetzt hab ich erstmal alle Videos geladen,
und jetzt kann ich hier irgendwie sagen, Elektrotechnik.
Zumal sie es ja auch noch scheiße machen.
Sie machen es ja auch noch scheiße.
Sie lassen ja auch noch alles im Buffer drin.
Noch viel schlimmer sind die Seiten.
Also was heißt sie machen scheiße?
Nein, sie machen es weniger scheiße, das hab ich versprochen.
Es gibt nämlich auch Seiten, die entladen das.
Die machen das alles mit JavaScript.
Und sprich, wenn du runter scrollst,
dann sind die gar nicht mehr auf der Seite, diese Dinger.
Da kannst du das gar nicht machen.
Eine der schlimmsten Sachen ist hier Discourse,
oder wie dieses Ding heißt.
Comments.
Das ist echt...
Das hier, genau.
Das ist auch so ein richtiger Webdesign-Cancer-Shit, Alter.
Guck mal, du kannst jetzt hier...
Du kannst hier nix suchen drin.
Du kannst nix suchen.
Weil, wenn du scrollst,
wenn du scrollst, entladen die oberen Sachen.
Guck, das sieht so aus,
das sieht so aus, als scrollst du die Seiten.
Aber wenn du seht jetzt, wenn ich schnell scrolle,
wenn ich schnell scrolle, seht ihr,
die laden per JavaScript im Hintergrund die Comments nach,
je nachdem, wo ich am scrollen bin.
Die sind nicht drin, das heißt, wenn ich hier unten...
Guck mal mal, hier unten, unten, Kommentar.
So, hier.
Linking to existing topics.
Jetzt gehe ich hoch.
Suche.
Und ich finde es nicht.
Mach das mal mobile.
Knallst mal eben das Datenvolumen weg.
Tja.
Es gibt nur im Jahr 2021 Technologien,
mit denen man feststellen kann,
ob einer mobile oder mit einem Desktop-Browser darauf zugreift.
Die Technologie ist einfach noch nicht da.
Technologie existiert noch nicht.
Jetzt mal Spaß beiseite.
Feststellen, ob es mobile ist,
beziehungsweise anhand der Bildschirmauflösung,
ist es überhaupt kein Problem.
Man kann komplett ohne Probleme feststellen,
mit welchem Bildschirm da einer drauf geht,
ob es mobile ist.
Und wisst ihr, was das Allerschlimmste an dieser Plattform ist?
Wenn ihr hier drinnen seid und drückt Steuerung F,
dann würde man eigentlich erwarten,
dass ein Search-Dialog kommt.
Aber nein, die haben Steuerung F überschrieben.
Das Webdesign 2021 ist teilweise so abgrundtiefer Müll.
Das ist der Wahnsinn.
So ungefähr hat sich die Stellenanzeige auch gelesen,
als hat das einer geschrieben, der da keine Antwort hat.
Aber die Antwort fand ich schon nett.
Ich habe schon durchaus den Eindruck,
als könnte man da arbeiten.
Die Stellenanzeige war halt ein bisschen fail.
So, jetzt habe ich genug aufgeregt,
aber ohne scheiß Webdesign ist es schlimm.
Es ist mittlerweile echt schlimm geworden.
Ja, den kenne ich.
Ich gucke es ehrlich gesagt nur relativ selten,
weil der macht ja mittlerweile auch relativ viele Story-Videos.
Man könnte fast sagen, so ein bisschen wie ich,
wo er so von seinem Leben erzählt.
Nur, dass ich bei ihm manchmal das Gefühl habe,
der Kerl hat auch schon irgendwie alles mal erlebt
und sicherlich auch durchaus ausgeschmückt.
Der wird auf YouTube gebannt.
Warum sollte der gebannt werden auf YouTube?
Der macht doch nichts Schlimmes.
Ja, genau, das ist natürlich wichtiger,
als dass man ordentlich die Kommentare durchsuchen kann.
Verstehe, verstehe.
Was?
Echt, was hat er denn gemacht?
Alter, was ist das für eine...
Was zum Teufel ist das für eine Website?
Die hat er absichtlich so schlecht gemacht, oder?
Google ist deleting...
Was ist...
Er hat einfach einen Strike gekriegt.
Ja gut, bestimmt wegen Hacker-Content.
Bestimmt wegen Hacker-Content.
Was hältst du von den Cellys?
PoC riecht gut.
Der macht Technik-Videos auf...
Oder IT-Videos auf YouTube.
Ja gut.
Die werden den, glaube ich, nicht bannen.
Da hat man bei Semper-Videos gesehen,
sobald der Aufschrei so groß ist,
wenn ein Mensch sich das Ganze anguckt,
ist das immer wieder vom Tisch.
Da ist schon was dran.
Ich muss sagen, eines der cringiesten Sachen,
das habe ich schon mal im Stream erzählt,
von einem...
Also ihr wisst, wenn ich einen Editor verwende,
dann im Prinzip eigentlich auch
auf der Konsole auch nur wippen.
Aber trotzdem, ich finde,
manche sehen das deutlich zu religiös.
Und zwar habe ich mal einen...
einen Konferenztalk gesehen,
von einem, der auch auf einer Ruby-Konferenz
von so einem Hardcore-Wimmer,
der hat auch immer den Joke gemacht,
wenn er sich verschrieben hat in der Präsentation,
I'm wimming too hard.
Ich weiß nicht, das war nach dem zweiten Mal nicht lustig,
aber...
Naja, uns...
Das war auf einer Ruby-Konferenz,
und der Typ, der war eh komisch, das war mega cringe.
Der hat gesagt, okay,
er erzählt uns jetzt mal was über guten Ruby-Code.
Und dann meinte der Typ ernsthaft,
in seinem Konferenztalk,
ja, also Leute, mal eine Frage an euch...
Also hat er so...
Hat das uns Publikum gefragt,
auf diesem Talk, hat das uns Publikum gefragt.
Was meint ihr, ab wann ist für mich
eine Funktion zu lang?
Ab wann...
Ab wann habe ich so das Gefühl,
da, das ist zu viel.
Und ich dachte mir so, ja, gut, was wird er jetzt erzählen?
10 Zeilen, 15 Zeilen, ich meine, das ist immerhin Ruby,
da kannst du alles relativ kurz und knackig machen.
Und der meinte,
ohne Scheiß,
ab der ersten Zeile,
also quasi, wenn eine Methode
oder eine Funktion länger als eine
Zeile ist, ist sie zu lang.
Wie stelle ich mir
die Programme von dem Dude vor?
Da findest du noch gar nichts mehr.
Der macht, der versucht dann
irgendeine Funktionalität einzubauen.
Ist kein Witz, war Ruby Talk.
Ruby, Wim, aber ich guck mal, ob ich das mal finde.
Warte mal, das muss ich jetzt mal schnell suchen.
Wim, Ruby,
Talk,
One Lines,
Code, Smell,
ich finde das bestimmt nicht mehr.
Youtube,
One Line,
Conference,
das All Camp, ne?
Ok, ne, keine.
Keine Ahnung.
Ne, der hat das ernst gemeint, der hat das wirklich ernst gemeint.
Klar, von dem hat doch jeder schon was gehört.
Ähm, kann ich nichts zu sagen,
ich hab nur die Einser.
Aber das ist echt der Witz.
Ich mein, hallo, eine Zeile,
das heißt, wenn du irgendeine Funktionalität implementieren willst,
brauchst du erstmal
insgesamt dann
zehnmal so viele Zeilen, weil du um alles
so was bescheuertes, Alter.
Ja,
hab ich, ich hab zwei.
Ich hab die Gosund,
Leute,
ich weiß, ich weiß, das ist Pain's Jam, ich muss den Standardchalk
wieder bringen.
Wie nennt man den Hersteller Gosund nach
Corona?
Gesund,
ha, null, huge Chalk.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, ich weiß,
Pain's Jam, Pain's Jam,
richtiger Pain's Jam.
Ähm, ich hab einmal Lida,
Lida,
die hab ich unten
geflasht, in der, in der,
äh, in der Küche.
Konnte man, haben wir im Stream geflasht,
das sind die, die ich kaputtgebrochen hab an der einen Seite.
Im Stream.
Und dann hab ich die SP112 mit USB.
Die haben wir erst letztens
im Stream geflasht.
Und
die funktionieren auch wunderbar.
Mit Custom-Firmware.
Ja, aber es ist immer,
es ist immer echt schwierig zu, rauszufinden,
was man, was man flashen kann und was nicht.
Weißt du, ob was Neues bezüglich
den Ebay-Windows-Keys, nee, keine Ahnung,
aber Windows-Keys sind so billig und du brauchst
theoretisch gar keinen, ich würd das nicht auf Ebay kaufen.
Ja, ja, ohne Scheiß,
genauso stelle ich mir das auch vor.
Total, totaler Fail.
Das ist genauso
fernab der Realität, genauso
wie, ähm,
die Leute denken,
das Programmieren so aussieht.
Moment, Moment.
Mit
Comments, by the way, mit Comments. Das ist glaube ich
übrigens, äh, Linux,
Linux Kernelsource.
Sekunde, richtige Hacker-Mood.
Aha, mhm, ja, ja.
Ja, ich hab's gleich, hab's gleich.
Ah, yes, excellent, excellent.
Also, beides äußerst
realitätsnah, ja.
Also, wer da echt nah dran ist,
ist dieser, ist diese eine
Competitive-Programmer,
der, äh, mit, mit, mit, mit
GWIM unter Windows am Start ist.
Ähm.
Dieser Typ, der eine Asiade.
Der da, der da, alter, der Typ.
Das ist, das ist nicht normal, ey.
Das ist nicht, das ist nicht normal.
Leute, GWIM unter Windows,
Alter, ihr müsst mal, ihr müsst mal zugucken,
wie der das, wie der den Code aus
kackt, quasi nur.
Passt mal auf, ey.
What the fuck?
Das ist so krass an.
Das ist richtige Hacker-Man, ey.
Und, und übrigens, übrigens,
der Tipp, nicht einfach nur
sinnlose Sachen, der löst
damit echte Aufgaben.
Also, ich könnte auch so schnell schreiben,
und wahrscheinlich, und wahrscheinlich
könnte ich sogar irgendwas
so schnell schreiben, was dann am Ende
kompiliert, aber nie, nie im Leben irgendwas
sinnvolles. Ja, gut, die ganzen
Competitive-Programmer stehen auf
C++. Aber,
aber, aber, aber, aber, aber,
aber, aber, aber, aber, aber, aber,
Competitive-Programmer stehen auf
C++.
Die Aufgaben sind nicht so
superschwierig, aber das,
die Schwierigkeit macht, macht die Menge
und, ähm, die Geschwindigkeit.
Also, ich glaube, die Aufgaben
würden wir mehr oder weniger
auch hinbekommen, alle, aber halt
nicht in der Geschwindigkeit.
Und, und vielleicht nicht unbedingt in C++.
Der, der Typ ist echt heftig drauf.
Vor allem, ich finde die Kombination
auch geil.
Geh Wim unter Windows,
aber nur plain-Sündags-Highlighting,
sonst nix.
Was zum Teufel macht denn Synchris?
Äh, ich würde mal vermuten,
also, dass es C++, ich weiß nicht,
ich würde mal versuchen, dass es so was wie ein
Flush oder so, dass er die Sache
noch rausschreibt, ich hab keine Ahnung.
By the way, kann man da nicht eigentlich
cheaten?
Also cheaten in Form von, dass man sich schon
total viele vorgefertigte Sachen,
oder muss man das
livestreamen? Weil ansonsten baut man
sich quasi schon die 50
häufigsten Probleme, die da dran kommen,
baut man sich einfach schon was fertig zum
Copy und Pasten und passt das nur noch ein bisschen an.
Das Chrome-Theme, das richtige Hacker-Man.
Ja, du machst Link-List, Binary-Trees,
so die üblichen Dinger halt.
Ey, der Typ, der geht aber echt voll ab, also
gibt's nix.
Der is Poggers.
Ja, Quick-Sword,
Merge-Sword, die üblichen
Dinger.
Ja, klar hab ich das mitbekommen.
Äh, irgendein, irgendein, ähm,
Jam ist
ist irgendein
Mime-Type
Package hatte
Probleme, jaja, das hab ich mitbekommen.
Das ist ein bisschen wie dieses
Is Odd, Is Even NPM Package, was auch NPM
kaputt gemacht hat.
Das stimmt wohl, ja.
Ne, da bin ich zu
Low-Brain. Ich kann mich im Stream
nicht richtig konzentrieren.
Äh, ich weiß nicht, ob das einer kennt,
wenn man, wenn man zugeguckt
bekommt und, ähm,
ich kann mich, ich kann mich nur zu,
sag mal mal, 80% auf
so was konzentrieren im Stream.
Das reicht für die Sachen, die wir hier
ohne Zeitdruck machen. Ihr seht doch, wie lahm
wir mit den einfachsten Dingern teilweise sind.
Was ist an G-Wim besser
als Notepad++?
Es ist was komplett anderes.
Also
Notepad++ ist halt ein
stinknormaler Text-Editor nach dem
klassischen Text-Editor-Schema mit
halt ein bisschen Funktionen wie
Sonntags-Highlighting oder, oder
irgendwelche Plugins und so. Also im Prinzip
ist Notepad++ ein klassischer Text-Editor
mit einem Eingabefeld
und du schreibst rein.
Wim, hast du halt die ganzen
Shortcuts und vor allem die ganzen, diese
diese Wim-Language, ne? Also zum Beispiel
was du halt in Wim machen kannst, um uns mal ganz kurz
zu zeigen, also
du machst jetzt, du hast jetzt hier irgendeine Text-Datei
so, äh, bla,
bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla,
bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, so, du hast hier irgendeine Text-Datei
und Wim ist halt big brain. In jedem
anderen, also wenn du das jetzt, wenn du das hier
jetzt, ähm, also das zwischen den
Anführungsstrichen, ne? Wenn du das
ändern willst,
dann musst du bei jedem Text-Editor den hier machen.
Dann musst du bei jedem Text-Editor hier hingehen und es löschen.
So, bei Wim
ist das anders. Bei Wim
gehst du einfach in die, ne, gehst einfach in die jeweilige
Zeile, wo du hin willst. Das kannst du auch
mit Doppelpunkt, äh, Doppelpunkt 7 machen.
Und dann sagst du einfach
C-I-Anführungszeichen und zack ist alles weg
und ersetzt. Ist halt easy, ne?
Und wenn du das Ganze noch öfters
hast,
ne, also
ups, aber
machen wir da irgendwie, machen wir irgendwie anderen
Tempel rein.
Alter, mein Wim lag leckt voll.
So, was du jetzt machen kannst, ist
was du jetzt machen kannst,
ist, du kannst, ähm,
wenn du das hier alles ersetzen willst,
so, dann kannst du sagen, C-I
das, ich will jetzt alles durch eins, zwei, drei ersetzen.
So, dann gehst du jetzt runter, machst
einfach nur Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt, Punkt,
und hast alle Sachen dazwischen ersetzt.
Ja, also
das hast du halt
in normalen Text-Editors nicht.
Was halt schon äußerst nice ist. Du kannst
auch so Sachen machen, wie, ich will jetzt alles
auskommentieren, da sagst du hier vorne den, zack,
Escape.
Ist halt, ist halt schon nice, was da alles standardmäßig
drin ist.
Übrigens, wusstet ihr, dass Wim zählen kann?
Ctrl-X, Ctrl-A.
Warum auch immer
Ctrl-X und Ctrl-A?
Ich hab kein Plastenschimmer, was Ctrl-X
und Ctrl-A mit Increment, Decrement zu tun hat, aber
ja, und by the way,
wenn ihr die Zeile unten drunter nur leicht
anpassen wollt, oh Mist, war das
nicht X?
Nee, Y, Y. Du kannst
quasi die Zeile oben drüber schreiben lassen,
noch mal, bis zu dem Punkt, wo du es ändern willst.
Es gibt total viel, es gibt total viel
Zeug in der Richtung, ja.
Ist also nice, und
das ist halt der große Unterschied zwischen so einem
klassischen Text-Editor und Wim
Magic.
Ja, gibts Gewimm-Golf und sowas, gibt
jede Menge. Increment,
Excrement.
Äh, na ja.
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Übrigens, wenn man
alles löschen will, man kann übrigens auch mit
G und G, wenn man alles löschen will, ne?
Da kannst du auch,
also wenn du alles markieren willst, sagst du einfach
V, äh, V-G.
Und wenn du D drückst,
löscht da alles, aber du kannst doch einfach sagen,
äh,
äh, Moment, was war das jetzt?
D, G? Ist auch
alles weg.
Also, es ist abgedreht,
das Ding, ja.
Gibt es auch Wim für Word? Nächste, mich würde es nicht wundern,
ob es einen Wim-Plugin für Word gibt.
VibroOffice?
Ernsthaft?
Wim-Mode für LibroOffice?
Kalkwriter?
Ach du Scheiße, Alter.
Ach du Scheiße.
Warum gibt es das für Word nicht?
Oh, ich will es für Word.
Aber für Word gibt es das halt nicht.
Dazu würden die meisten Leute wohl eher sagen,
das ist ja das coole an Wim.
Ähm, ich weiß nicht,
inwieweit du da schon was mit gemacht hast, aber
das ist ja das coole an der Wim-Sundags.
Du musst dir nicht so viele Tasten-Kombinationen merken.
Also, es ist im Vergleich zu
irgendwelchen anderen Texteditoren,
oder sagen wir mal auch so was wie Emacs,
die extrem Tasten-Kombinations-heavy sind,
ist Wim
nicht wirklich
Tasten-Kombinationen-heavy, also sprich,
Wim hat eine eigene Editiersprache.
Also, du musst jetzt nicht
zum Beispiel merken,
Ctrl,
X, I, B
ist Change,
Klammern und sowas.
Du hast bei Wim solche Sachen wie zum Beispiel,
also wenn du, ah gut, muss man jetzt wieder
irgendwas hinschreiben.
So.
Du hast da so eine Sündags, du hast zum Beispiel,
haben wir hier nochmal Dinger, so.
Du hast zum Beispiel sowas wie C,
wenn ich C drücke heißt das immer Change.
Wenn ich W drücke heißt das Word.
So.
Also, es fängt immer mit C an.
Und dann gibt es zum Beispiel,
C, I, W ist Change, Inner Word macht keinen
Sinn, aber funktioniert auch.
Aber wenn ich dann mache C,
I, Quotes,
dann changet es die Quotes in drin.
Also sprich, du musst dir
diese Wim-Sprache merken, nicht wirklich
die Shortcuts und die ergibt nach einer
Zeit auch
zumindest ansatzweise Sinn.
Wim 3D, ja Wim 3D haben wir hier
im Stream ausprobiert zu starten, es hat leider
nicht funktioniert.
Du wirst zum Beispiel auch den Zuschauern erkannt, ich wurde schonmal von
2 Azubis,
eigentlich 3, 3 Azubis erkannt.
Ja.
Das mag ich nicht, im Browser mag ich es nicht, weil
Maus ist immer noch das beste im Browser.
Oh, es ist 2,24 Leute.
Ich muss ins Bett.
Was für ein Ding, da wo das
Archiv programmiert wird.
Ok Leute,
machts gut.
Mach kurz das Stream.
Schaut mal, schnell ob ich jemanden hosten kann, warte mal,
Frasier oder so, ist der Frasier am Start.
Frasier, Frasier da.
Na gut, der muss auch arbeiten.
Semper Video ist am Start.
Die Provider.
Ja, Host was Semper Video passt.
Exquisite.
Ich bin da aber nicht mehr, ne.
Also ich bin dann,
ich bin gleich weg dann, ich komme nicht mit drüber.
Aber ihr könnt
ja mal vorbeistellten
und eine Runde Wuppgasm oder was auch immer
spammen.
Hat er eigentlich, hat er eigentlich custom
Emotes mittlerweile?
Aber ich glaube Semper Video
ist jemand, der wird niemals
Ayayaya aktivieren auf seinem Channel, oder?
Irgendwie macht er nicht so den
Weep Eindruck.
Ne, gibt's, gibt's nichts.
Ne, natürlich nicht.
Okay Leute, macht's gut.
Bis dann, tschüss.